اجواء من الصدمه خيمت على الجماهير
الغفيره التي شاركت من مختلف مناطق قطاع
غزه في تشييع ضحايا حريق جباليا
[موسيقى]
21 مواطنا معظمهم من الاطفال والنساء هم
افراد عائله واحده قضوا في حريق المبنى
السكني في جباليا شمال القطاع جهود انقاذ
افراد العائله لم تحل دون وقوع الكارها
حركه حماس
ومن خلال قياداتها التي موجوده في الميدان
وتواصت مع ذوي الشهداء تسند هذه العائله
المكلومه وتقب بجانب ذوي الشهداء وتعمل
بكل امكانياتها لاسنادهم همم وتسخير كل
الامكاناتها في هذا الصدد
في تشييع ضحايا حريق جباليا ومن جديد تتجه
الاتهامات للحصار الاسرائيليه وتعنده
الاحتلال في السماح بادخ معداتي الدفاع
المدنيه والمستلزمات الاساسيه لسكان قطاع
غزه
فليل قطاع غزه اكتشح بالحزن والحسره بعد
ما التهمت النيران منزلا لعائله ابو ريه
في مخيم جباليا تجمع افراد عائلته
للاحتفال لكن سرعان منقلبت اجواء البهجه
الى كارثه
اطفال بينحرقوا قدامك وانت مش قادر تعمل
لهم شيء ام بتصرخ على الناس والاهالي ولكل
الناس بتتفرج عليهم ومش قادرين يعمل لهم
التحقيقات الاوليه الرسميه عازت الحادثه
الى وجود بنزين ومواد قابله للاشتعال داخل
المبنى مما صعب مهمه رجال الدفاع المدني
الذين حرمهم الحصار المفروض على قطاع غزه
منذ اكثر من 16 عاما من الحصول على
المعدات الاساسيه المطلوبه رغم تهالك
المعدات المتوفره لديهم هبه كيلو الجزيره
من مخيم جباليا شمال قطاع غزه